después de casi 13 meses de
estancamiento a la investigación del
puerto de beirut El juez tare pitar
encargado el caso ha abierto un nuevo
proceso contra el ex Primer Ministro
libanés hasandiab y el todopoderoso jefe
de la seguridad general avas Ibrahim y
de otros dos exministros de su gobierno
acusándolos de homicidio por las más de
220 muertes en las explosiones del 4 de
agosto 2020 causadas por la explosión de
más de 2.000 toneladas de nitrato amonio
que habían estado almacenadas durante
años y sin ningún tipo de seguridad en
un hangar del puerto de beirut El juez
vital había sido apartado el caso porque
estaba bajo una investigación de algunas
de Los Altos cargos acusados que habían
abierto un caso contra él y era por eso
que estaba paralizado desde diciembre de
2021 en las últimas semanas las
asociaciones de los familiares de las
víctimas del puerto de han estado
manifestándose en el Palacio de Justicia
para exigir que se reabriera el caso y
para que regresara el juez vital
asociaciones entre ellas amnistía
internacional así como diplomáticos
occidentales han estado acusando en
repetidas ocasiones de la falta de
transparencia y obstrucción a la
justicia por parte de las autoridades
libanesas Por no querer levantar la
inmunidad política de los acusados de
hecho todos los altos cargos que han
sido llamados por el juez vital no han
querido participar en el proceso